major developments in the brick Cavanagh
confirmation battle the woman accusing
the supreme court nominee of sexual
assault
now signalling she may be open to
talking to lawmakers but not on Monday
lawyers for Christine Blasi Ford say
she's prepared to testify next week if
the terms are fair and ensure her safety
which is important we're also learning
that Republicans on the Senate Judiciary
Committee are trying to get answers
about this allegation staffers
interviewed Cavanaugh under oath and
have reached out to potential witnesses
but Democrats they're not participating
even though the facts are not clear the
left is already claiming Cavanaugh is
guilty here's Democrat congressman Adam
Schiff they should get to the bottom of
this and it wouldn't take that long to
do this is the same crowd that waited a
year to fill the last vacancy during the
Obama administration on the Supreme
Court so why this rush and I think they
realize they have a very imperfect
candidate in fact they may have a
candidate who's committed attempted rape
and then there's this new line of attack
coming from Democrats senator Kirsten
Gillibrand who is not asking the FBI to
investigate these claims the White House
judge Kavanaugh has not asked to have
the FBI review these claims is that the
is that the reaction of an innocent
person it is not so how can this be
settled here's Judge Napolitano with
some interesting analysis subpoena her
she decided to go to the press if they
subpoena doctor for it if they subpoena
the therapists notes if they subpoena
dr. Ford's husband who according to dr.
Ford was there when this incident was
was recounted then they can interrogate
well would what we know so far about
this case would that stand up in court
absolutely not it's too it's too
ephemeral it's too indefinite it's too I
don't remember I don't remember I don't
remember right most judges wouldn't even
let a jury hear it okay so here we are
now Jessie we know that she's willing to
come but not on Monday and under terms
that are not yet established she does
not get to dictate the terms that she
testifies to the Senate Judiciary
Committee it's not her role and
you know I believe she's got a lot of
lawyers around her that are getting
cocky and they're trying to drag this
thing out and it's clearly a delay
tactic there's just tons of new
information that really begin to cast
doubt on the the honesty and integrity
of the Democrats on the Senate Judiciary
Committee first of all they still have
not turned over the original letter that
Ford sent to Dianne Feinstein they've
been hiding that from the Senate
Republicans they're not acting in good
faith on that Ford as well has deleted
her social media account right before
she went public I wonder what she didn't
want people to see their N Ford's
attorney also said only on Monday this
is just three days ago quote my client
will do whatever is necessary to make
sure that the Senate Judiciary Committee
has the full story and the full set of
allegations to allow them to make a
fully informed decision and then
literally three days later changes the
entire story doesn't want to testify but
may testify next week but only on our
terms
this is not how people operate in good
faith Katz's lawyer Katz the lawyer for
Ford are ignoring phone calls and emails
from the Senate investigative staff and
as you mentioned the open the Senate
Democrats aren't even participating in
the conversations with Cavanaugh and the
alleged witnesses where they are under
oath Cavanaugh has been under oath to
the chief counsel of the Senate
Judiciary Committee under the penalty of
perjury
he's been under oath that way and Ford
has not decided to go under oath also
very interesting it's getting extremely
political ford has hired a former
Clinton and Biden advisor it doesn't
look good if it's become this political
at this point it looks like the
Democrats are making a partisan play
here to delay and delay and delay and
there's less thought being paid to
getting this alleged victims story out
there in an open forum and I can't
believe I'm quoting a senator and
reading this letter the Grassley letter
to Diane finds a master class of letters
he's one of the best letters I've ever
read and he goes through point by point
how many of you Oh
Ted Cruz no and he says this request for
the FBI demonstrates a fundamental
misunderstanding of how the FBI operates
and you understand this you know that I
don't want to read up but I just want to
highlight it a lot I just want to
summarize it okay the Democrats are not
operating in good faith and the Senate
Republicans have bent over backwards to
accommodate this woman and have done
anything possible to allow her to get
her story out there and so far all we're
seeing is delay unfortunately the other
thing is that senator Tammy Baldwin of
Minnesota had booked a fundraiser with
the accusers lawyers but now has
canceled that because it probably didn't
look too good but I saw you and you
think that the Republicans have not been
accommodating to her I don't think this
is a question of how the Democrats have
acted that's actually not what we're
talking about here what we are trying to
determine is how we can get to the
closest version of the truth that we can
know decades later I think she should
testify I also think that Cavanaugh
should testify again and I think Mark
judge who she alleges was in the room
should testify if there are any other
witnesses they should testify I think
she should do it quickly
I don't think Monday is some magical
date on the calendar that if she doesn't
show up that day she's clearly lying
she's working to find a date next week
that works this woman never wanted to be
public she has death threats she's had
to leave her house this is not a
pleasant experience for anyone involved
so let's give her the opportunity to
find a day next week that works and not
impugn her reputation when we haven't
even heard from her yet good Tuesday
workers Tuesday better than Monday how
dare you ask such a question this isn't
about the Democrats and how you don't
like their behavior it's about how to
get dr. Ford Cavanaugh Marc judge any
other witnesses to testify to find out
what truth we can and then the Senators
can can determine whether that changes
their vote or not that's how the process
works
it seems to me everything everybody's
been pretty accommodating except for one
group we talked about the death threats
and how part of the terms is to
guarantee her safety who's not a who's
against that no one's saying I'm sorry
you're gonna have to take the bus and
wear a sign around your neck
no one's going to ask you that everybody
understands death threats if you work in
the media we get it if you want to know
about going into a den of lions just
watch Dana lash at the at the CNN at the
CNN Town Hall over gun control okay
people understand danger but that's not
that can't be used as protection against
coming forward after you have made
something public which is possibly
destroying a person's life you say well
how dare you say it's could destroy this
man's life because according to Adam
Schiff he is an attempted rapist well by
Adams shift Adam Schiff what could he
have done what where is he could you
accuse him of something how would his
family feel if he was accused of
something this is weak this is not the
America that I know where you have due
process where where a policy is guilty
of attempted rape maybe even though the
evidence is kind of ambiguous and
including the accuser isn't even sure
but we can just say they're guilty we're
in it we're in a time right now that is
an incredible threat to our civilization
because we are in doing an institution
every single person is vulnerable every
person your husband your husband your
father your son because if all of it
takes is an unsubstantiated accusation
in which the accuser can then say whoa
hold on not so fast
you're all screwed you're all screwed
he's gonna gain the whole thing is Jesse
hit on something that I think everybody
here needs to digest
they are absolutely correct these Senate
Democrats are not stupid they are fully
aware of how FBI background
investigations work I actually did
backgrounds for the federal government
as a Secret Service agent let's be
crystal clear what they are and what
they aren't they are criminal history
checks they are under no circumstances
criminal investigations there's a
difference if I'm investigating you for
the Supreme Court I check your NCIC
history and I check what your neighbors
to see if you've been arrested if the
neighbor says to me hey Murray maybe
dealing drugs out of her house I don't
investigate that as a Secret Service
agent I contact the police I would go to
her house
because all things the Senate Democrats
are not stupid and they know this so
them asking for the FBI to do a criminal
investigation either speaks to their
grotesque ignorance which is not true or
the fact that as Chuck Grassley
accurately stated it is purely an
obstruction tactic I did this that does
not happen they do not do criminal
background checks on this full stop on
that well we'll see what happens that's
our makes that our permanent tag line
what happened that's from Trump you know
he's right about everything